la prochaine crise la dette
merci au large vous plaît merci bonjour
la soudaine c'est une catastrophe
l'a3 rapport disciplinaire a visé une
urgence je m'en foutais rêvons
je m'appelle madame mais si j'ai
réfléchi à un projet qu'on pourrait
faire tous ensemble un concours
c'est le concours national de la
résistance et de la déportation salaires
le ton truc quand il ose vous savez très
bien qu'on va se planter pas voulait
qu'on se tape la honte si on fait ça
c'est bizarre parce que moi j'ai
beaucoup plus confiance en vous que vous
n'avez confiance en eux mêmes
madame pourquoi on parle toujours des
juifs mes enfants et les adolescents pas
de religion la nationalité n'est pas
plus jeune qui a comme concours je pense
moi que vous avez énormément de choses à
dire là dessus vous vous trouvez ça bien
raisonnable de faire passer ce concours
à votre seconde
moi je vois ça comme du temps perdu puis
du temps que vous pourriez consacrer à
d'autres élèves qui le méritent plus
seniors ce qu'on a fait une randonnée
tout tracas vous ne vous parlez pas ça
ne change pas
faut pas parler comme des élèves il faut
en parler comme des enfants chacun avec
sa différence et avec sincérité et ça je
sais que vous êtes capable de coeur
à travers des vivres les films les
documents tout ça
c'est un peu comme si on faisait des
rencontres
[Musique]